Squared,
welcome to the Royal Geographical
Society and it's nice latest
intelligence squared debate on democracy
in India.
India's hailed as the world's biggest
democracy and I think it was Hugh
Patrick who made the point that every
second person in the world living in a
democracy is actually living in India,
which is quite an astonishing thought,
but the question is,
what does Indian democracy mean?
Is it the glue that holds India together
and allows it to flourish and drives
it's creativity and vitality?
Who is it a curse that's encouraged
corruption and social division and
perpetuated poverty?
Is it India's Achilles heel and that of
course is the motion tonight.
Democracy is India as a Kelly Kelly's
heal,
but you will know that because on your
way in,
you will already be asked to give your
initial verdict and I'll give you the
results of that initial poll a bit later
on.
But as you'll know,
if you've been to one of these events
before,
you're also going to be asked to Costco.
Costco,
cast your vote again.
When we've heard from the speakers to
see if their scintillating arguments
have swayed you in one way or another,
and just a reminder,
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
the process,
what you do is you tell your ticket in
half and worked with either the fall or
the against slip,
so I don't mix them up and if you can't
make up your mind then just throw the
whole ticket in and register a don't
know,
vote in the ballot box.
Well,
it's time to get going.
We've only got til 8:30 and I'm going to
invite our for debaters to the podium
for opening speeches.
They know they've each got 10 minutes
each and after each speech I'm going to
ask the other two on the opposing side
to quiz them briefly for just a couple
of minutes to give them the first star,
but challenging the speaker.